Wow. It has been a whole year and a half since I have been here online,
sharing my lifestyle and talking about traditional marriage.
I want to show you guys.
This is the very first video that I ever made that went viral,
and it was the video that started my whole channel.
And when I posted this,
this went viral for a lot of bad reasons,
but it also still remains to be my most liked video on my channel.
And, yes, these are ads.
These are 50s ads from the 1950s.
But why is it that this video has so many likes?
Maybe it's because when other women like me see pictures like this,
that, yes,
our ads, they're not real pictures.
It still represents a lifestyle.
It represents a simple way of living.
It represents traditional marriage.
And you know what?
It makes us women feel warm and cozy inside
seeing videos and pictures like this.
These ads represent a more simple life,
and that for a woman,
being a wife and being a mother is enough.
I remember when I posted this,
I got so many comments, and people were trying to say, well,
where the women of color?
But I had about 200 followers before I posted this video.
And when I made this video,
I was choosing ads of women that looked similar to me.
That was all. And I remember thinking,
did I do something wrong?
Do I need to delete my post?
But then I started posting more online
and I started realizing
that there is a lot of negativity about having a platform online.
And that was just something I came to accept.
The traditional wife community
is not pushing this lifestyle onto anybody.
We are simply sharing the feminine freedom we have
from choosing this lifestyle over having a career.
And that is okay if you want one or the other.
Since it's been a year and a half,
I just wanna thank you all so much for the support
and love that you give my page.
You all are the reason I keep going.
And I have to say,
after I posted that and the response I got from that video,
it really. It really triggered something in me to keep going
and keep posting about a life that is so misunderstood.
And so that's what I've tried to do here on my channel.
And, um, my content is not perfect.
My.
The way I speak and the way I portray things is not always perfect.
And I'm sorry about that.
But I am a human.
And I hope you guys understand
there will be times that I delete things
that maybe I'm not the most proud that I posted.
And that's okay.
It's a learning journey.
And yeah, being here online has definitely been a journey.
But anyways, I just wanted to kind of give a little
remembrance post to my first post that went viral ever.
And I wanted to thank you guys for your love and your support.
Have a great day. Bye.